I'm Ted wit enstein I've been assisting
professor noir
charged task force over the course of
the past year and we're very grateful
for the presentation just to remind you
guys what the format will be a few quick
opening remarks from our Provost
professor Pollock professor nordhaus
will maybe give a brief overview of the
presidential carbon charge task force
report which of course you can also view
in full online in the announcement from
President Salva and provost Pollock
transmitting the report earlier this
week following the presentation of the
report we'll just sort of open it up to
Q&A from the audience we have some other
members of the task force who are with
us who might also participate and share
some of their thoughts and we'll have
about a little bit of a discussion so
thank you very much for your time and
let me introduce provost Pollux thank
you so welcome everybody suitably not
hot earth day today so I wanted to just
start by thanking some people I want to
thank the Lord house having chaired the
committee I think this this task force
it is kind of a model example for how
you can get students and faculty and
staff working together on serious
university problems you know its
challenges and I particularly want to
thank the students involved who I hear
from everybody were just terrific for
the faculty press the node house doesn't
need any introduction from me he's a
former Provost he's part of the foremost
economist working on this problem in the
world and personally speaking he's a
mentor and friend the other faculty
involved included Dean Snider for an som
law professor Dan st who recently was
the energy commissioner for Connecticut
from forestry bride pressure Brad Wren
tree who chairs Yale sustainability
Advisory Council former dean of som
Sharon hasta another teacher of mine
former Deputy Provost and formatted
charitable science department Francis
rosenbluth the director of the Yale
climate energy institute mark pagani and
the chair of radiology
participated Peter Glazer's so it's a
kind of an all-star group kind of
amazing that have put together a group
like that to look at a problem like this
and i also want to thank the staff
people who worked on this John Bali air
ginger Chapman Linda lorimer and
especially Ted now the report bills
going to go through in a minute and go
through some of the details I want to
emphasize where we are we have this
report and I want to separate my only
wear it when I see is going forward to
let me do my own view first of all I'm i
will admit it I'm kind of an enthusiast
for this thing I really like this idea I
think it's the right idea I think it'd
make puts Yale in the right place I'm
pretty excited about it but it doesn't
mean it's going to happen right there's
only lots of opinions this is kind of
the beginning of the journey not the end
of the journey with a lot of people have
a lot of views perhaps as lots of views
in the room and I think part of the part
of the excitement is going to be seeing
what happens what happens next but the
part of the many parts that I like and I
could go to all of them but i won't i
think I likely that the bill but the
part that I do want to emphasize is how
this is right for Yale why this is the
right environmental practice and policy
for yale yale Yale's mission is
educational and for Yale to try to
design something like this and try to
put it in practice as a sort of
experiment is incredibly important
educational thing to do it so it's it's
a lesson for the wall we're already
attracting enormous detention in the US
as a from our peer institutions as we
try to do this and even if we fail to do
this I've already given away that I kind
of hope we're going to succeed but even
if we fail to do this we're going to
learn a lot from what it takes to try
this and friend from failing so I think
this is win win I mean I think it's big
win with a capital W in capital I on
Catalina we get it done but it's a win
even if we fail because we're going to
learn how hard it is nowhere i'm already
rising extremely hard it is now if it's
going to work and it's going to work as
an educational thing that means clear
communication and clear dedication and
the person who is best at explaining
why this is what this idea is how things
like revenue neutrality work why pricing
of carbon is a sensible way to think
about the world the person who's best
capable in the world to do that is Bill
note house so let me sit down and stop
boring you and let the person actually
knows about this talk about it so bill
gloves definitely been so I could listen
to distinguish talk about the only
question is where are we push the wrong
button there there were so what I'd like
to do is walk walk through with you the
findings recommendations pitfalls
advantages of carbon charge at Yale and
what I want to do is let me just start
out by saying failure is not a word in
my vocabulary dispersion is not a word
in my vocabulary two steps forward one
step back there's a phrase in my
vocabulary so I don't know what will
happen with this program very much
hoping will go forward I i think the
other members of the task force do as
well but at this point is just a
blueprint and we're handing the
blueprint off to the people who build
things in the purpose office the
president's office facilities office and
around the campus but let me go through
the blue green so I thought it might
might be useful to start with the major
recommendations at the outset so you can
get a feeling with a general structure
and then we'll go back over the details
okay first we were asked whether year
should introduce a carbon charge and the
answer is yes we would like to do it
starting in the next academic year and
will be phased in over a period of three
years I'll talk
at the end about why a phase in such a
reasonable thing to do but the answer
the first question is yes we should I'll
talk later about the pricing issue but
or the charge you the level of the
charge we spent a fair amount of time on
this issue and we ended on what we think
is a consumption conceptual and
ethically correct level of the price
which is what's called the social cost
of carbon I'll explain that little thing
there alternative that we could have
chosen but this is a conceptually clear
and then once you've got the concept
it's pretty easy to implement something
that's very central to this proposal and
I think most puzzling to most people
most when I've had most difficulty
understanding myself and explaining is
the idea that this is a revenue-neutral
program and what that means is it it has
charges on all the units but has rebates
to all these Ministry of units and those
net out to zero so this is not a tax
this is not something to raise revenue
for worthwhile programs with many
worthwhile privilege but that's not the
point it is it's central to the design
of this and think to the acceptability
of this that we've seen as something
that's not a tax not a subsidy either
but that its revenue neutral across the
different administrative units of the
University now to be revenue neutral you
have to have some way of levying the
charge and the way it's done is on the
unit's net emissions so might be this
the School of Music it might be
athletics it might be medical school
might be library and there would be a
big I'll explain this a little more
later but there
a little given base level of emissions
you would be charged on whether our unit
would be charged on whether the
emissions were greater or lesser than
this pace and the basis set in such a
way to a first approximation so that the
sum of the basis is the sum of the
emissions for the university so the sum
of the differences is also is zero and
that's how you achieve round your
neutrality now there's an issue of what
the footprint is and we have a person
who's the Czar of footprints and joined
us we'll hear about that but the
question is what does this include as
include central campus does include
medical school does include remote
facilities and the answer is it's a
conceptual answer that everything the
university is operational control and so
that's basically you can think of
everything we're university pays the
energy bills and it excludes things that
the university is financial control so
if we own a company in the endowment
that would be outside the purview of
this but if we run a company and that's
in the purview so too so you can think
of you can think of Yale's obligations
as being ones relating to its
operational activities and ones relate
to its financial activities the National
activities are governed by a different
set of principles we actually don't have
a set of principles for operational
activities and I see this as as a set of
principle that applied to operational as
opposed to financial ownership so that's
the that's it so those are the five key
points and what I want to do is go
through those sketch over those in the
next few minutes now let me say just
remind you of the presidential charge
presidents olive a that yes the blue he
asked the task force for blueprint and
that introduced in early this year so
this is pretty early this year
for piloting in the next academic year
so to a first approximation we're doing
with the present fast let me mention the
members of the task force I'm not going
to read all of them Provost actually
mentioned all of them I would like to
say that it's been a it's been a great
people group of people to work with
these are people who are knowledgeable
about different corners of the
University it's a very complex place
different schools different colleges
different operational units and we we've
been very lucky to have the people
involved who given their time and also
I'd say that we've had a lot of advice
and counsel people inside the university
and people outside the university we had
a we had a meeting in December of
experts from not just Yale but from
companies and universities around the
world even and we got a lot of advice
from that so this is this is the cast of
characters okay so let me say something
about carbon pricing so carbon pricing
has emerged at the statistics may speak
more generally for a minute as a central
tool for reducing greenhouse gas than
co2 emissions we moved to people's
thinking from quantitative limitations
to pricing and the primary reason is
that pricing is something that affects
everybody big people with little people
the government's the firm's individual
consumers and in a very even-handed way
and so one of the insides we bring to
this is why not do that a Yale as well
from the quantitative targeting of
earlier era to a price type of targeting
today now I should say that while this
is experimental innovative I it's a
brand new there are carbon prices that
have been introduced in different places
the European Union has had them for
about a decade British Columbia ads
actually had a carbon tax for its four
years and actually it's a model in the
sense that it was a revenue-neutral tax
they actually did differently obviously
cut governments two different things
before the institutions do but they did
the same thing of 11 attacks and we
hated it and it's been very very
effective there many companies use
internal carbon pricing and a few
companies have introduced it non energy
companies Microsoft and Disney and
they're basically is there you they have
a different approach than we do they're
using it to recoup the costs of their
sustainability programs rather than as a
way of good for damage purposes and I
would let me just say that yells carbon
charge is not a Mickey Mouse idea it's
it's not one discover sustainability
it's not an o-level it's not for public
relations purposes it's really designed
to have to be stained and also to affect
our behavior so let me let me say a
little bit about the purpose I will go
over this pretty quickly because been
mentioned these but one thing that we
don't often think about is that we're
presumably on hope we hope moving into a
high carbon price world and we want to
be ready for that you don't want to be
sitting there in without our different
programs being prepared for that so this
program is one that when we get to a
hard carbon price world we can just shut
it down because we will be ready we will
be prepared we also want to introduce
the idea carbon pricing at an
institutional level as an institutional
innovation it has it's not that it's
never been done but we want to think
about how you actually flow these
decisions down to decision makers at
different levels of the institution and
just again to emphasize the idea of
prices as a tools or decentralized
decision-making
rather than having the president or the
provost say do this to that you actually
present people with it with prices it's
a little more expensive to do that the
more expensive to use energy maybe a
little more expensive to fly around the
world a little less expensive to get on
the telephone and tell people's behavior
toward low-carbon activities and then as
the pros did mention and I would
emphasize well let me back up at our
December meeting professor Frank or lack
of Stanford said one thing about the car
about yields program no matter what you
do you are not single-handedly go to
solve the climate problem you are not
through individual steps you're going to
take here in New Haven going to make a
big dent on climate change and I think
we recognize that but we think our role
is not to actually change the global
emissions plan to introduce policies to
introduce ideas and what I call
institutional innovation that's they
show the kinds of tools that can be used
not to build an iphone but to change the
way people's behavior people pay people
bay I think I will just quickly say that
on live on the prices there are
different concepts we settled on what is
known as the social cost of carbon which
is the estimated cost of an extra ton of
emissions we think that's an ethical
standard that we would recommend rather
than something like what you can buy an
offset for what a cost for your
sustainability program once you accept
that there's a that has been carefully
analyzed by the federal government I've
been litigated by the federal government
it's used in federal regulations and so
we don't need to rediscover this it's
right there we suggest using it if you
take that charge and yells estimated
emissions the total gross charges would
be about 12 million a year and then okay
all those getting baited so the net
charges would be zero something about
the boundary i mentioned
the footprint if you like or what they
call in tax theory the tax base of this
would be operational control and that we
thought the best way to define that is
if the university directly or indirectly
pay to the pills the energy bills to
operationally pretty clean concept and
so that's what we adopt and therefore it
can it covers all our signs central
campus medical campus west campus remote
facilities athletic facilities and solar
and it would be levied on all units just
as energy charges are now now okay so if
you ask well what the lots of different
as any of you study this know there are
lots of different emissions of carbon
dioxide emissions and other kinds of
greenhouse emissions and then their
direct emissions indirect emissions and
they're in direct indirect emissions so
when you draw the line here so we we
recommend it at the outset to only
include Energy Commission emissions from
energy use either direct that we burned
here on our campus or indirect that we
buy from somebody else the electricity
we purchase from someone else those are
what are known as the ugly technical
language is scopes one in scope student
and I mentioned what those are now you
can go on to other scopes scopes three
and those get more complicated
everything everything has some carbon in
it you tell your your telephone your
telecommunications your air travel your
cement use and so on and we we don't
have the same kind of measurements there
that we do on energy use so we think we
would like to include air travel which
is extremely energy intensive and it may
be some other associated with
construction but we're not ready for
that we the university or not ready for
that and so we think that needs to be
studied carefully before implementing
but we would like to move on we would
recommend
we want God again that the this concept
of revenue neutral has been mentioned
and I'll just say we its revenue neutral
not in the sense its revenue neutral
forever that's 0 for every unit but it's
unit its revenues it's 0 for everyone
some together emphasizing i mentioned
that use for so used in different places
so a kind of keen point here is that if
you think of a unit which has zero if it
doesn't do anything then if it reduces
its emissions it gets a hundred percent
of the benefits in the sense that have
been reduced emissions by 10 units it
gets ten times forty dollars of a rebate
on the other hand if it decides to build
a whole new building and has a large
emissions associated with that then it
would pay the amount of that so it's a
key idea here that you don't get your
programs aren't affected if you behave
in an average way but you have an
incentive to reduce emissions and you
get a hundred percent of the benefit of
that now I won't get into Yale budgeting
because it's a very painful subject this
is painful because it's it's me it's the
most obscure system known to humanity
any of you who dealt with and I know at
least one person that's rules dealt with
it probably just feels pain and thinking
about it other tools in an earlier era
no it's a very complex system but
they're outside there are two kinds of
units inhale there are those who pay all
the bills or lots of the bills and have
a venom at a bottom line net to net
revenues and net operating income less
operating expenses and then other units
and don't even see the bills and so in
some way or another roughly half of the
schools and departments around schools
and units around the campus pay their
bills and see their energy bills
and roughly half don't so what we're
proposing this I'm oversimplifying what
we're proposing is for the units that
see the bills we or they have well
managed and large budgets we pass the
carpet shark through to them even if
they don't pay the energy bills now but
there are other units residential
colleges logistics department maybe some
small libraries or just small units they
don't actually have very large budgets
and don't manage them in itself in a
negative way and we would for those we
need to use what we call behavioral
approaches coming out of a naval
psychology and consult with the
President on that behavioral programs
experimental programs to see what works
to give people more awareness of what
their energy and emissions are energy
submissions are and how ages finally on
phase in late in the day after now I
thought we could just go right on full
steam ahead next year and then I went to
dr. somebody and they think they didn't
say you're crazy but they said you know
we're not quite ready for this we can't
realistically do this all next year and
so explain to me patiently while I said
that's how it's correct so what we're
recommending is that we phase it in we
pick a few units for the next year big
units medium sized units small units and
then gradually face it in over the next
three years with full implementation
with the third year and we also
recommend them in good academic a
tradition that be studied at the end of
the period to see how effectiveness so
that's it that's an overview you can get
all the details in the report again I'd
like to thank our task force and people
who work with us and in my matter we
have some people here that might say a
word and I'll start with Sharon Oscar
who chaired one of our groups on pricing
thank you so this was actually a really
terrific Lee interesting task force for
me to be on I feel like I learned a lot
about both the science and the way the
university works so I just want to say a
couple of things about what we hope for
from this charge and some of the
complications that I think people in the
audience can help us think a little bit
about going forward the goal is this
okay okay sorry so we are intending as
bill said to set the carbon charge at
the social cost for an economist the
advantage of doing that is as decision
makers think about things like how to
turn on the lights or whether to shut
the windows the cost that they are going
to face and making those decisions
include all of the private costs they've
always faced but also will now under
this charge include the cost of the
social damage they're doing to the
environment and to society when they
don't shut the lights off so that's the
sense in which using that social cost as
a charge is very appealing and our goal
then is when people make decisions that
they include that social cost in their
decision making now there's the place
where we need a little bit of help
because what imposing the charge will do
is to make salient to for example the
Dean of my own business school what the
cost is of the activity of the people
under his purview the way more difficult
thing to do is to make that George
salient to the individuals inside of
each of the institutions having Dean
Snider know that shutting the lights off
imposes a charge on the school and a
social costs on society is very
different from having one of our
students understand the impact of his or
her action and how it is that the deans
and the decision-makers at the budget
level
each the parts of the University are
going to translate their understanding
and their incentives into the creation
of incentives for all of the
decision-makers scattered throughout the
university will be a very interesting
challenge and I think a lot of our
learning is going to be involved with
figuring out how the different Dean's
push down and really decentralize this
charge so that everybody sees it and
feels it and acts according to it so
that's where I think we're going next
and I think for those of you scattered
at the University that'll be an
interesting challenge hi everyone I'm
Jennifer Miller house Kim one of the
student representatives on the task
force just to speak a little bit about
student perspectives and how we use
student opinions in shaping this
recommendation so we held a student
forum hear that hopefully many of you
came to in the fall and I just want to
confirm that we really took a lot out of
that we actually got a lot of ideas from
that student forum and so I was really
excited to be able to bring a lot of
student opinions and suggestions to our
meetings I know there's a lot of support
and desire among students to really make
sure this charge was impactful and
broad-reaching and I think that we
really did a good job of balancing that
with practical the practical aspects of
this charge as bill sort of alluded to
it's going to be a sort of process
learning how to implement this charge
and Yale budgeting I've only learned a
little bit of but it is truly very
complex and so I think it's really
important to keep in mind that a charge
on some aspect is really much better
than no charge at all and the way that I
think we get to having the type of
impact that we want and having this
charge be applied in every area that we
want is to make sure that it's applied
first in these areas really well and
really effectively and doesn't overly
burden you know those who need to
implement it and so I think that there
was a lot of student desire and and my
personal desires well was to make sure
that this charge does ultimately cover
some scope 3 emissions which are those
non energy emissions such as air travel
which is a really large part of our of
our universities footprint but I do
think that we need to make sure we get
the right data so then we make sure when
we do implement it we implement it
really effectively so I certainly want
to hear student opinions on on our
recommendations and certainly any you
know if you have criticisms absolutely
we'd love to hear those but I do hope
that people keep in mind that I think
scaling this up over time in a really
effective way will be the best decision
I as bill mentioned I was in charge of
the footprint committee so just to sort
of reiterate what I just said about
scaling up over time to cover more
emissions that was also sort of the
thought process in terms of footprint we
wanted something that was really clear
and really simple in terms of what was
included and what was not included in
the charge and we thought that once you
started sort of making exceptions for
certain you know units or buildings you
can really open the door for for
everyone asking for an exception so we
wanted a really clear footprint that was
really easy for people to understand
again trying to set us up for the most
success moving forward as we try to
scale it thank you i will just say that
that was a tremendous learning
experience for administrators and staff
to hear from Professor nordhaus
professor SD professor oyster and under
really understand how academic
approaches to sustainability into carbon
pricing could translate into operational
concepts of how the university is run
and so I really think there's something
special about the task force and the
energy it created in terms of thinking
about how the academic life of the
University how the operations of
university have student life at
University can really be integrated
together four approaches to
sustainability and climate change and so
I think that was one of the most
interesting things to sort of understand
and witness in the scope of this process
and it has really sort of inspired I
think a lot of other
schools have been interested by this
I've already been sort of getting calls
from some of our peer counterparts
interested in this concept professor
Nordhaus mentioned the other
universities that participated in
December I think there's a sort of
growing recognition if you could think
about areas where Yale really could make
an impact on climate change areas that
really could be if replicated by Yale
and other peer schools could have
tremendous impact this might be one of
them so with respect to Clark carbon
pricing if there is a model here even at
a smaller scale even imperfect in some
ways but something that could be a start
that could spread to a number of other
like institutions you're beginning to
sort of get at a larger national problem
that I think a lot of people are excited
about addressing so Yale is of course an
innovator in a variety of different ways
and so institutional design is one of
them and if you could sort of think
about how academic research and teaching
can inform a university policy this is
just an interesting example of that so
this is obviously the beginning of the
conversation and not the end nothing is
sort of final in terms of how this will
move forward but I think in terms of
starting off the conversation this is a
really interesting first step so I'm
very appreciative to Professor Nordhaus
so thank you so what I'd like to do is
just sort of open this up to questions
from any of you maybe just say your name
and who you're where you're from in the
University and we'll take it from there
we'll pass a microphone around just to
make sure everyone can hear you please
in the back
sandra gomez from mechanical engineering
of material science ah we all been
facing I mean the idea is very good can
you hear me yes yeah the idea is very
good of course but it would rely on an
extremely efficient organization which
he'll is not so you're you're proposing
to hit on the emissions we have no
control on the emissions we basically
depend on controlling the emissions on
the temperature we settle on our
thermostat for example the thermostat in
the building a word with that the
dilapidated Mason lab depends on
whatever physical plants decides to do
and sometimes we call in because the
temperature they claim they've set is
the wrong temperature so as a result we
usually freeze in the summertime and we
are overheated in the wintertime so
there is no way in my in my
understanding of what you're trying to
do to hit on the emissions unless you
reform physical plant which is probably
a very tall order well i won't i won't
get into the debate about the pros and
cons of that but actually i want to
address the deeper question of whether
people have any control I can't can you
hear are not sure is this on don't on
whether people have control over their
emissions I think I think we
underestimate the ways in which we do
now we don't have a hundred percent of
control but we have control over
lighting button actually one of the most
important ways we have control is in our
laboratories over the equipment we use
and that is something where most people
around the campus actually pay
relatively little attention to the
energy efficiency or lack of efficiency
of the equipment it's a particularly
pernicious problem because of the
incentive of federal overhead structure
we're often equipment will be exempt
from overhead and the energy isn't even
charged so you've got a whole set of
incentives about what kind of energy
using equipment what the energy use is
what is bought and this is not just in
laboratories and these are so this is
pretty pervasive so one of the thing let
me say this is this is a this is a quite
a difficult issue to try to think of how
we would include not just structures and
lighting and heat but energy using
equipment and choices there we had some
ideas in the report but we recognize
that that's typical I have to say you
have a really important point though and
then this Jennifer also made which is
that a lot of people just don't pay
attention to this this is just not on
the radar screen not many people as to
what what their energy use is and what
they can do so a very important part of
this we think is to actually make people
aware of it by giving them information
on both of those two things and that's
more difficult but we think that is part
of the program and finally I might say
that we're we're very interested in
doing some experiments so we think if in
fact we do go ahead with this we would
do this in in the spirit of research as
well as as emissions as to say we would
do some experiments where we would
random do some randomized treatment
across departments or across schools
across residential colleges so you can
do different treatments and you actually
see whether makes it so if you're right
it doesn't make any difference at the
end of five years everybody's right on
baseline and that are different at all
well it actually is really useful
information but we do have experiments
out there that suggests that these kinds
of things information about use
information about how you can change
behavior and incentives all those do
matter for energy use um I I think again
I think it's an excellent point so it
speaks to my question about whether we
can get some behavior change from the
charges one of the things that we
thought
ask for us is that if you tell people
and this perhaps reflects the economics
thinking of some of us if you tell
people there's some resources at stake
either that they have to pay you that
they can receive it creates some
incentives to them to go to the
facilities people and say we'd like to
be better what can we do and so we've
suggested to the administration that
resources may need to be put into the
facilities area to provide some
consultation two groups about what they
can do you know short of rien salay ting
and fixing the heating system on an
everyday basis to actually achieve
better carbon emissions control hi I'm
the son Robert doob route from the
school of public health so I have one
brief comment and then one question so
the comment is that I mean that I think
like the issue of the you know things
permeating down from the Dean is
important in terms of individual
behavior but there are also important
structural solutions so just for example
in my building the lights are on you
know 24 hours a day you know day and
night when the a lot of the lights don't
need to be on for most of that period
and you know so simple solutions like
motion sensors and you know like in the
hallways you know maybe having every on
nights and weekends having every fourth
light on instead of all the lights on
you know could save a lot of energy so
that's more structural than individual
behavior and then my question is in
terms of the net carbon emissions and
having the historical levels be the
baseline did you talk about like
gradually reducing bass lines so that
you know in order to force you know
behaviors in terms of lower emissions
I'll just take your question and not the
common we actually proposed two
different ways doing this one was
you set a baseline by University total
and the other one is the way you suggest
which is to have a percentage change
that's in advance and it could be some
target or it could be some historical
change each of those has advantages and
disadvantage I would just say the
disadvantage of the second one let's say
you set an ambitious target ten percent
a year or something like that the
disadvantage of that is that you're
going to start raising a lot of revenues
from the units and you might might end
up with the unit's having a net charge
of two three four five million five
million dollars a year so the advantage
of the first plan which is revenue
neutral every year which is you set the
baseline to move with the University
total average is that it's actually
revenue neutral here by here we may both
of those out I've used the revenue
neutral year by year because it's easy
to easier to explain but both of those
were laid out in our report and just to
respond really quickly I'm into your
comment I think it's a great point but I
think to Sharon's point there's also a
behavioral aspect to that all of a
sudden you know the payback period on
making those motion sensor lights
becomes a lot shorter and then there's
also sort of the behavioral aspect of
making the person who has the control
over those lights and the
decision-making ability to put those
motion sensors in all of a sudden more
aware that it might be something worth
considering so I think even though there
are you're right that a lot of these
changes are structural they're small and
getting someone to take the initiative
is a really important first step so
we're hoping to to instigate that just
follow up on your first point though I
might mention that part of the
sustainability initiative that the
president announced last fall was an
increase in the budget for energy
efficiency around the campus
I've been asked do we do too much do we
do too little do we do about right i
don't know the answer I know the
University of California system is doing
much more than we are but they're bigger
campus but i do think one of the things
we hope will come out of this will be
attention to the cause of issues that
raised doing careful analytics of what
you're getting where the payoffs are I
talked to John bowler that of facilities
and lighting actually is one of the big
initiatives in the next few years so I
think I think I think actually think
facility gets a pretty bad rap around
the campus I think if you would have to
spend you spend more time you spent time
not recommended because your other
things to do but we spent fair amount of
time with facilities hearing about the
programs in it there's a lot going on
but as mentioned just one other point
when we went with under you other
universities so one of the key issues
you've got to measure that you can't
charge anything unless you get a mission
you can't get emissions unless you
measure them so you get a measurement
and monitoring around the campus I was
really surprised eel is way in many of
these other universities they even don't
even don't even monitor buildings and
don't even have many careful
measurements of building so I think
that's one place I felt very good about
not just yell but this program was we
actually are we're not it's not perfect
but we're pretty far along in terms of
the basics of just pure measurement of
what what different buildings in
different units do a James ball with the
school of Forestry first I want to just
echo the thanks for the tremendous work
and the decision coming out and
personally very excited about it my
question is in regards to one the
observation that we have a lot of
diversity across Yale and it'll be
interesting to see how in different
environments we have this grows or is
met with rejection in different
environments but we all have a mother
Yale above us and my question is I think
some wood associate that
culture of mother yale is one of
abundance and wealth than being able to
have all that that why brings and i
wonder if this program being implemented
implies a kind of shift in identity or a
cultural shift for what it means to be a
member of the Yale community Yale is
about we say it in the management scope
of people say to all kinds of different
ways educating leaders for business and
society I think Yale you may think of it
as abundant mother Yale but i think we
think of it as socially responsible Yale
and I think that's the spirit in which
this this really emerges been pollux
trying to make us not be so abundant
feeling anyway my presentation we
thought very carefully I mean there's a
big debate debate at this university as
in other universities about divestment I
one thing I think of that as ethical
responsibility with respect your
financial investments we've thought a
lot less about ethical responsibility at
our operations what we do on campus how
we I mean we do with respect to say
animals and other things but in this
area I see this as extending our feeling
of social responsibility to operational
activities and it's a pretty it was
quite I was quite interested how little
people think of that as an aspect of
four universities of ethical respond
that was a responsibility I think in
business as more of it but it actually
went a little operational responsibility
ethical responsibility I thought this
was actually stepped down that that road
hi I'm Gabe rissman i'm a member of yale
college um I came 20 minutes late so if
this is already covered let me know but
when I was reading the port I report I
noticed that there was a overall focus
on reducing consumption and a huge part
of the reason why national or any other
level of carbon tax is good is that it
encourages a transition to alternatives
or renewables because fairly prices the
the bad and allows room for the good um
and I don't really see any focus on
renewable source witching in this plan
and I was wondering if that's because of
the unit by unit nature where yell
facilities controls what renewables go
where and it's not really up to the unit
by unit building manager and is there
any way to allow for renewables because
I think that would be an important part
of the carbon charge that's a really
good point i think we see you could
think of production consumption I think
you made the point that this report was
about consumption and not production I
don't I mean we and economics department
don't don't produce energy we just use
it so that's true actually most of the
units most of the administrative units
around campus facilities thinks about
that and I think part of the action I'm
not speaking for the facilities but I
know it's part of their thinking about
it to what extent we can use renewable
such as sore as a substitute for fossil
fuels one of the things about using a
carbon price is it gives you a benchmark
so you can say okay if putting up a
solar array is saving carbon a thousand
dollars a ton it's probably not a very
good idea if it's saving carbon at ten
dollars a ton that sounds like a good
idea so I think one of the most
important parts but it's actually giving
you a benchmark for decisions it's not
just a floor above Cabot's but it gives
you some guidance on should you change
the lighting here should you choose you
install motion
should you put in a big solar array out
of the athletic wheels you can't just
you don't just do it you actually use a
bench mix it well okay what what is it
costing what's electricity million and a
certain at this forty dollars a ton or
whatever price of carbon is it is it pay
for itself so that's actually gives a
lot of discipline to the process as well
I think it also could play a really
important role in terms of growth of the
University and a new construction
because it will be factored into not
only will it be used as a price to
analyze you know different decisions in
building new buildings but it also makes
units think really closely about their
space and if they want to grow that
space I think renewables could be a way
in which they you know counterbalance
that growth um Peter hers yale school of
forestry um my question is about those
sort of shared services that everyone at
yale takes advantage of specifically
data centers how are those getting
integrated into the el carbon plan and i
know that Wes guidance is just installed
a ton of solar so maybe there's some
connection there this gets into the
tangle of Yale budgeting and actually
I'm not sufficiently knowledgeable to
answer that I team i'm saying i t's in
the vice president finance
administration so how that is that
correct yes cool so how that's going to
I don't actually know whether that is
therefore going to be something that
will be charged to the vice president
finance administration's budget and if
there are some enormous growth of
computer clusters that will be charged
there I think those are the kinds of
details that we did not have time or
expertise to determine part of the
problem with the your budgeting is
things get charged to all different
kinds of things and you can't always
like spaghetti you can always find out
where they're being charged so and I
think this is actually one
important what my sense is though that
the the solar arrays in west campus are
not going to be part of that West Campus
about to but I'm not sure about that but
I think this is an issue we need to in
general peel peel apart all these
different budgets so we can make sure
that decisions and charges budgets and
decisions are in the same room in the
same office and same you know we don't
want people making decisions about
energy and somebody else paying the bill
because that's that's a recipe for just
pour a noun put decision to values so I
don't know the answer to that
specifically but there are some more
sort of simpler examples in which the
energy build is bill is paid by
allocating those energy uses to whatever
you know three departments share a space
there's an allocation calculation so
potentially one solution could be just
simply also allocate the charge since
it'll be attached that energy usage in
the case of data centers though I'm not
sure how that energy bill is is
allocated oh yeah I have another
question um so this is about the scope
three that Jennifer talked about um so
um it seems like even if there's no way
of applying a or yet way of applying a
carbon charge it seems like well
professor Nordhaus said earlier that the
measurement is the first step that he
was surprised that other campuses didn't
even monitor what emissions come from
what buildings I don't know if this is
within the scope of the carbon task
force but it seems that a measurement of
kind of the the emissions that come from
commuters and scope three also includes
investments so potentially the endowment
portfolio just measuring the carbon
associated with that well if not
applying a specific charge to that could
allow for some sort of incentives to
reduce this go three if you if you can
measure it and see how it goes up and
down over time even if that's not a
forty-dollar charge some sort of
incentive yeah so I think that's a
really important point and I think
we certainly recommend that in several
areas of scope 30 missions specifically
air travel to start we start trying to
measure that better right away you can
sort of split scope three emissions into
two different categories areas in which
Yale has operational control in areas in
which Yale doesn't so air travel for
example that Yale is paying for
absolutely we could ultimately implement
a charge on that commuting emissions is
much tougher because Yale doesn't pay
your gas bill to drive your car here and
so be much more challenging to implement
a charge on that at the same time the
office of sustainability is really
working towards measuring all of these
scope three missions much better and
those under which Gale does have
operational control I think it's really
important that we start trying to see
which ones we really can measure and
which ones are you know large enough and
impactful enough that we should really
put the time into measuring accurately
so that we can ultimately hopefully you
know not too many years down the road
implement a charge on them and air
travel is certainly the first one in
that bucket and so I think right away
we'll start trying to work with the
university of budgets office and
figuring out how we can get you know
appropriate metrics in place for that I
would say also I don't think anyone on
the task force thought the only thing
the university is going to do is a
carbon charge so you know more bike
racks maybe changing the pricing of
parking more video conferencing kinds of
things are all things that the
university you know is doing is moving
forward on that's kind of independent of
the carbon charge kind of area some of
them will be encouraged I think actually
by the carbon charge but it's not as
though there are not going to be other
environmentally sensitive things that
the university does and is there any
plan to to measure the emissions
associated with the endowment in
addition to all the other scope three
stuff that was not discussed in our task
bar so we do we actually discussed the
issue is the issue of what we covered
and there are they there are two
different ways of doing measuring the
institutions but putting one is
operational control the others financial
control and
we settled on operational control that's
what sustainability people thought
that's what most of the people in the
task force thought I think the endowment
is another set of issues and that's just
I have lots of I have lots of opinions
on that but our task force did not
tackle a vision sandra gomez mechanical
engineering again i have a hard time
understanding the whole day a week an
appeal to people in terms of their
ethical behavior so you have to behave
right and try to save energy minimize
your carbon footprint but the system of
of carbon chargers or carbon taxes it's
based on providing incentives or
disincentives towards good behavior bad
behavior so the thing I very great
difficulty understanding for example you
made the example party if you were to
cut down dramatically the cost of
parking for motor box for example that
would be an obvious thing to incentive
eight use of water bikes with smaller
carbon footprint than cars but you have
example yet here instead we're looking
at the program that they too overall is
revenue neutral and if I understood
correctly there is no mitigation
incentive for university as a whole to
go in that direction in the direction
will be using the overall carbon
footprint so where is the incentive this
incentive kind of thing that makes this
thing work it's my chance I don't know
if my questions yet I guess I have a
different conception the University you
do i think the university is me and you
and the people in this room it's the
people making the decisions the people
running the schools that people with
grants the people buying equipment the
people deciding whether to fly or drive
or stay home that's what i think it was
the university so kind of a big holding
company for all of us and so what we
need to do the problem is if you have
these goals only at the top they never
come down to the people who are actually
making the decisions so the purpose of
this is to actually
the incentives flow down to the people
who buying the equipment ultimately who
are flying or deciding whether to fly or
not just an end who are working with
others to make decisions about energy
use this is not part of the plan but let
me give you a simple example let's say
that air travel was included so now
flying someplace costs an extra hundred
dollars and it's not going but could
easily cost a hundred dollars round trip
business class flight to to Europe or
something like that be more maybe 500 I
don't know i think that when influence
people's behavior and so that's so
that's actually one that it's
interesting that's one that the task
force was in a way reluctant to do but
that might be the one that would be most
real to people and actually have that
the most salience to people if suddenly
they the cost of these airfare there in
their airfare went up by the amount of
the carbon i am behind your point
perfectly and so but that scope was
three no no yumiya i usually another
example score was one or two well again
the example equipment was the one how
would you this when you there people
don't take into account I don't even
know when they buy equipment what the
energy uses on it some do but but many
don't let me neither how many of us when
we buy our computers actually do the
lifecycle calculation on the energy
costs I know I don't maybe some people
in this room do I'm sure some of you but
how many people leave the computer on
all night again they go okay well okay
so so just one other thing I think you
make a very good point and when the when
the people from facilities made a
presentation they emphasized just what
you did that the things that individuals
can do on their own by themselves on a
day to day basis right tomorrow or
relatively small there are relatively
small fraction of energy use and
emissions but when you include other
things
is is a building open 24 hours a day or
not do we actually work with the
facilities to get lighting that's not on
all the time do we give a system where
one of the buildings we heard one light
goes on all the lights go on and then
there are there other they're all kinds
of and then the other things as well so
I when you expand it from my turning my
heat on and off which might be zero to
the other activities that we can do
jointly particularly at the departmental
level they emphasize the departmental
level which is the building level the
scope for changes increases and then we
think on the longer term we have changes
in structures equipment growth of growth
facilities or more intensive use of
space and I think that even there the
scope for actions even larger hi my name
is Stephanie winnetka a student at the
School of Forestry and I just also
wanted to say thank you for taking the
time to really think this through I
think it's been a very thoughtful
process so far and I would just say that
I'm excited to see how it unfolds the
semester in the next few years and my
question is I was wondering if
throughout this process you've thought
about a specific role that you'd like to
see students a poor in and Beyond kind
of just knowing about that it's
happening and making personal or
individual changes but kind of really
more institutional support either within
schools or at the university wide level
and kind of what recommendations you may
have for students who are interested in
getting more involved that's why do you
suppose I have ideas i don't know that i
should say them cuz i know it's approved
ensena fir that doesn't sent it all like
you I'm being where I'm being recorded
though I think there are going to be a
lot of opportunities especially around
scope 3 right because we have a huge
issue with not having the measurements
in place and it's going to take a lot of
time to actually better understand how
we you know take airline trips that you
know faculty and staff are taking and
actually translate that into carbon
emissions and then figure out how we can
you know simply and adequately you know
implemented
charge off of that so in cases like that
I think there's a lot of opportunity for
student involvement in terms of studying
mechanisms to effectively do that and
then also just putting in the hours
because it's going to be time consuming
I I'm going to say something that all my
colleagues probably won't like very much
but I think you should go see your your
chairs your Dean's and say hey what are
you doing did you read this report what
do you think what are you doing what are
we doing let's get off our Duff let's
get involved and one things I'm
particularly excited about is actually
doing experimental programs and programs
that bring awareness of these issues to
the different units not just and I think
two areas to stand out the Faculty of
Arts and Sciences in the Medical School
where you have all you lots of months of
departments and they don't pay attention
to any of this because they don't pay
the bills and it would really be
interesting to see how we can get these
two big entities which are roughly
eighty percent of the university if you
include all those associated parts how
we can get them in the involved so I'd
say go talk to people if you if you
think this is a good idea go get your go
get people in your school or department
interested in say hey what are we doing
let's pay attention yeah I also want to
add that I think sometimes students also
don't realize that they see the
University in a way in which a lot of
sort of staff you know especially
facilities doesn't get to see it so you
know i can tell you John boullier is not
in dorm rooms at 2am and realizing that
they get really really hot and so
students open the windows in the winter
because it's too hot in their rooms and
so things like that are stories we've
heard for more anecdotally but if
students actually sort of take the
initiative to understand that you know
this has implications and that you know
they can you know alert notify the
correct people you know what happens to
buildings do all the lights go on when
you're studying at 1i am that's not
something that you know a lot of people
know and so I think there's also just an
awareness to report these things that's
important mr. Provost you go people can
do
gentlemen from mechanical engineering I
i think we are sometimes guilty of
feeling a little bit more powerless than
we are so on the faculty side um the
provost office I get many many emails a
day many many many emails a day where
there are personal incentives to have
rules changed university so you know
I'll get several days saying can I use
my research proj to buy my children's
clothes by the way the answer is no with
as little incentive personal executives
to get things Indian people not be like
crazy so we know you can if it's the
case they've made some bad that the
heating is bad or isn't individualized
enough then that's what you can log in
there you have a no Center to lobby for
that and that makes a difference I think
that Jennifer made earlier that all
these changes you make like putting in
it switches that make place go off and
they should all thermostats on
individualized the rate of return of
those I get a much better come too much
so I don't quite buy it there were quite
as powerless as we think we are when I'm
getting loaded in the progress of this
gray simply powerful to me so maybe I'll
just say I think we're ready I think we
should wrap this up people have other
places to go we're done on the task
force with our formal work we conveyed
the report to the president Provost we
very much hope this goes forward as it
goes forward I think I think they're
going to be lots of ramifications
they're gonna be lots of effects and
sure we don't anticipate all of them I
hope they're Pleasant and not unpleasant
I hope their favorable ones but this is
this is a pretty substantial program and
a pretty substantial incentive this is
this is not a Mickey Mouse program as I
said so I will personally be very
interested in enrolling this forward and
seeing how it looks at how many of you
come out to hear it and talk about it
today we'll stay involved and I
particularly want to thank the task
force for its wonderful work in
collaboration and developing everything
we've done thank you thank you Dad
you